me he dado cuenta de que para muchas
personas la parte más difícil para
resolver un problema de movimiento
rotacional es tener en mente todos los
nuevos nombres de las cantidades que hay
así que en este vídeo quiero hablar de
todas las diferentes variables como el
desplazamiento angular velocidad angular
y aceleración angular explicando qué
significa cómo las podemos encontrar y
cómo las podemos calcular vamos a
hacerlo veamos este ejemplo digamos que
tenemos una pelota de tenis a la cual le
atamos una cuerda y giramos esta pelota
de tenis en un círculo si hacemos esto y
queremos comenzar a definir variables de
movimiento rotacional que describan
justamente el movimiento rotacional de
esta pelota
quizá la cantidad más básica que podemos
encontrar sería cuál es el ángulo que
recorrió esta pelota de tenis en su
movimiento digamos que tenemos aquí la
pelota de tenis y va a rotar hasta acá
podemos definir una cantidad que nos
diga cuál es el ángulo que ha recorrido
esta pelota y esta cantidad es el
desplazamiento angular y tiene el
símbolo del
ya que teta es el ángulo y delta te está
va a ser el cambio en el ángulo así que
esto realmente es teta final menos teta
inicial por ejemplo si nuestra pelota de
tenis comienza aquí en 0 y termina en
180 la teta final será 180 menos la teta
inicial que es de 0 por lo que el
desplazamiento angular va a ser de 180
grados api radiales y si comenzamos en
cero y recorrimos un círculo completo y
después otro círculo completo nuestro
desplazamiento angular será de cero
técnicamente va a ser de dos
revoluciones completas que serían 720
grados o 4 pirra dianes y no siempre
tenemos que iniciar desde cero nuestra
teta inicial podría estar aquí en 180 y
llegará a 270 en cuyo caso el
desplazamiento angular sería de 90
grados api entre 2 radiales y debemos
notar que el desplazamiento angular es
un vector es decir tiene una dirección
así que debo ponerle un signo de vector
arriba y tengo
la dirección está dada por la regla de
la mano derecha ponemos nuestro pulgar
de la mano derecha hacia arriba aunque
me queda un poco grande este pulgar pero
si nuestros dedos representarán esta
parte curva la rotación de la bola
alrededor del círculo nuestro pulgar va
a representar la dirección de este
desplazamiento angular es la regla de la
mano derecha así que tenemos que usar
nuestra mano derecha sacamos el pulgar y
si nos imaginamos que nuestros dedos
giran con este mismo sentido que está
girando la pelota si ustedes toman su
mano la ponen arriba de la pantalla y
hacen que sus dedos tengan el mismo giro
que tiene esta pelota entonces su pulgar
debe estar apuntando hacia ustedes es
decir el pulgar estaría apuntando afuera
de la pantalla y esta sería la dirección
del desplazamiento angular aunque
podemos decir que ustedes pueden
encontrar esta dirección en la mayoría
de los problemas simplemente decidiendo
si el movimiento es en sentido
antihorario o en sentido horario
típicamente decimos que el sentido
antihorario es positivo y es
el horario es negativo esa es la
dirección en la que rotamos los ángulos
en sentido antihorario son positivos y
los ángulos en sentido horario son
negativos pero la opción es de ustedes
siempre y cuando sean consistentes con
esta así que no me voy a preocupar
demasiado de la dirección real de este
vector vamos a pensar en esto en
términos de sentido horario o sentido
antihorario quitamos esto y es así como
definimos nuestro desplazamiento angular
y típicamente lo medimos en radiales y
no usamos grados por una razón que
ahorita les voy a decir y el nombre para
este símbolo de acá es theta y debemos
mencionar que esto es análogo a como
definimos el desplazamiento regular si
imaginamos que la pelota de tenis se
está moviendo en línea recta
el desplazamiento regular se define como
la posición final menos la posición
inicial a la que llamamos delta x y a
esto lo llamamos el desplazamiento el
cual medimos en metros y ahora sabemos
cómo cuantificar el desplazamiento
angular la cantidad de ángulo que esta
bola rota
o al recorrido pero otra cantidad que
puede ser útil es la tasa a la cual está
viajando a través de este ángulo igual
que aquí arriba conocemos el
desplazamiento pero si queremos saber la
tasa a la cual se está llevando a cabo
este desplazamiento en términos de
cantidades lineales regulares a eso le
llamamos la velocidad de la pelota y se
define como el desplazamiento entre el
tiempo aquí vamos a tener una cantidad
similar pero será la velocidad angular
que se define de forma análoga a la
velocidad regular y si la velocidad
regular es desplazamiento entre tiempo
la velocidad angular va a ser el
desplazamiento angular entre el tiempo y
el símbolo que usamos para representar
la velocidad angular es la letra griega
o mega que parece una doble 1 pero es la
letra griega o mega las unidades de
omega o la velocidad angular serán de
radiales por segundo ya que delta theta
o el desplazamiento angular está en
radiales y el tiempo está en segundos
como las unidades de la velocidad
regular son metros por segundo la
velocidad angular tiene unidades de
radiales por segundo pero qué significa
la velocidad angular está omega
representa la tasa a la cual un objeto
cambia su ángulo en el tiempo digamos
que aquí comienza la bola de tenis
para recorrer este círculo con calma
esto quiere decir que la tasa a la cual
está cambiando su ángulo es muy pequeña
y tiene una omega muy pequeña en cambio
si tenemos que esta pelota de tenis está
girando rápidamente la tasa a la cual se
está moviendo en círculo será muy grande
lo que significa que la velocidad
angular o mega también será grande así
que la velocidad y la velocidad angular
están relacionadas no son iguales porque
la velocidad nos dice cuántos metros
están siendo recorridos cada segundo y
la velocidad angular nos dice cuántos
radiales están siendo recorridos cada
segundo pero si tenemos una velocidad
angular mayor también tendremos una
mayor velocidad y así como la velocidad
es un vector la velocidad angular
también es un vector así que le ponemos
una flecha arriba de esta omega hacia
qué dirección apunta pues técnicamente
vamos a usar la misma regla de la mano
derecha que vimos anteriormente cuando
determinamos la dirección del
desplazamiento angular de nuevo si está
rotando en sentido antihorario podemos
considerarlo
y si está rotando en sentido horario lo
consideraremos negativo vamos a quitar
esto y vamos a definir nuestra última
variable de movimiento angular y quizá
adivinen cuáles tenemos el
desplazamiento regular y el
desplazamiento angular tenemos la
velocidad regular y la velocidad angular
y el siguiente paso lógico en esta
secuencia de variables de movimiento
angular será la aceleración que para las
variables regulares se define como el
cambio en la velocidad entre el cambio
en el tiempo y para definir una cantidad
análoga angular esta será la aceleración
angular y se va a definir usando en
lugar de el cambio en la velocidad
regular entre el cambio en el tiempo
esta va a ser el cambio en la velocidad
angular entre el cambio en el tiempo y
la letra que usamos para denominar la
aceleración angular es la letra griega
alfa esto es alfa y parece un pececito y
nos va a representar la aceleración
angular de un objeto y qué significa
esta hace
anular el de las unidades nos ayuda a
comprender esto si las unidades de la
aceleración regular es metros por
segundo por segundo la aceleración
regular representa la tasa a la cual la
velocidad está cambiando en el tiempo y
aquí abajo tenemos la misma definición
análoga aunque las unidades aquí van a
ser radiales por segundo por segundo así
que la aceleración angular representa la
tasa a la cual está cambiando la
velocidad angular y cómo se verá esto si
tenemos esta pelota que está rotando en
un círculo si está rotando a una tasa
constante no tendremos una aceleración
angular ya que o mega la velocidad
angular no está cambiando en otras
palabras si está rotando a una tasa
constante no tendremos un cambio en la
velocidad angular lo que significa que
no tendremos una aceleración angular
pero si comenzará moviéndose lentamente
y comienza a aumentar su rapidez
aumentando la velocidad angular entonces
tendremos una aceleración angular ya que
tendremos un cambio en la velocidad
angular de este objeto y como cualquiera
aceleración esta aceleración angular
puede aumentar la velocidad angular y
aumentar la velocidad de algo o puede
hacer que vaya más despacio el objeto
disminuyendo la velocidad angular pero
si la velocidad angular permanece
constante y está rotando en un círculo a
una tasa constante entonces tendremos
que la aceleración angular es cero lo
que significa que alfa será igual a cero
y de igual forma que todas estas
variables de movimiento angular la
aceleración angular es un vector igual
que la aceleración regular y la
dirección de la aceleración angular será
la dirección del cambio de la velocidad
angular si esta pelota de tenis está
aumentando su velocidad
entonces la aceleración angular tiene la
misma dirección que la velocidad angular
y si la velocidad angular está
disminuyendo
entonces la aceleración angular va a
apuntar en la dirección opuesta a esta
velocidad angular y en este punto no me
extrañaría que ustedes me dije
porque tenemos que definir estas
variables porque tenemos que definir
estas variables angulares cuando tenemos
estas variables regulares aquí y la
respuesta es por la misma razón que
definimos todas las variables en física
porque nos resulta bastante conveniente
hacerlo por lo que estas variables
angulares nos van a ser muy convenientes
para describir a un objeto que está
rotando y por esta misma razón imaginen
que queremos escribir no solo la pelota
al final de la cuerda sino que también a
todos los puntos que están en la cuerda
si nos limitáramos solamente a usar
estas variables de movimiento regular
tendríamos problemas se dan cuenta de
que esta bola da vueltas a este círculo
en cierta cantidad de tiempo pero cada
punto en esta cuerda también recorre una
circunferencia en la misma cantidad de
tiempo por lo que la velocidad de la
bola será mayor que la velocidad de los
puntos en la cuerda que se encuentren
cerca del centro y ya que a todo le
lleva la misma cantidad de tiempo
recorrer este círculo pero el círculo
que recorre la pelota tiene una mayor
circunferencia al menos comparado con el
círculo que recorre el pedazo de cuerda
que está más cerca del centro de la
circunferencia por lo que cada uno de
los puntos en la cuerda tendrá una
velocidad diferente y será menor
conforme nos acerquemos al centro de
este círculo por lo que describir este
movimiento usando solamente la velocidad
regular sería toda una pesadilla y sí en
cambio usamos la velocidad angular no
tenemos que todos los puntos en la
cuerda incluyendo a la bola recorrerán
la misma cantidad de ángulo en la misma
cantidad de tiempo no se mueven con la
misma cantidad de metros por segundo
pero si se mueve en la misma cantidad de
radiales por segundo ya que cuando la
bola ha rotado dos pirra dianes o un
círculo completo cada punto en la cuerda
también ha recorrido o rotado dos y
radiales si la bola y la cuerda
mantienen la misma forma y esto es lo
bueno de todas estas variables de
movimiento angular cada
punto en un objeto rígido tendrá el
mismo desplazamiento angular la misma
velocidad angular y la misma aceleración
angular no importa cual punto elijamos
el desplazamiento angular de la
velocidad angular y la aceleración
angular serán las mismas para todos los
puntos en este objeto en este objeto que
rota y antes de que esto se vuelva
demasiado abstracto hagamos un ejemplo
digamos que esta bola comienza aquí en
reposo y rota todo esto hasta llegar a
este punto en cuatro segundos por lo que
comienza aquí en reposo y le lleva
cuatro segundos rotar hasta este otro
punto y digamos que cuando la pelota
llega a este otro lado va a 1.57
radiales por segundo y digamos que esta
es la velocidad angular final bueno
ahora vamos a encontrar cuál es el
desplazamiento angular pues en este
ejemplo la pelota comenzó acá terminó
acá el desplazamiento angular será de pi
radiales o 180 grados cuál será la
velocidad angular pues como comenzó en
omega inicialmente es cero en este punto
de acá y al terminar nos dicen que la
omega final fue de 1.57 radiales por
segundo por lo que me pueden decir bueno
qué hacemos con esta fórmula pues si la
usamos veremos que recorrió irradian es
en cuatro segundos lo que nos da 0.7 85
radiales por segundo al cuadrado y me
pueden decir a ver esta omega no
corresponde a la omega inicial o la
omega final bueno esto corresponde a la
omega promedio es la velocidad angular
promedio entre los puntos inicial y
final el reposo significa que esta omega
inicio en 0 la omega instantánea fue de
0 y la omega instantánea al final o la
velocidad angular final es de 1.57 por
lo que debemos tener cuidado ya que
estos son valores instantáneos no serán
necesariamente igual a la velocidad
angular promedio podemos encontrar el
valor promedio tomando es
cambio en theta entre el cambio en el
tiempo pero no necesariamente nos va a
dar la velocidad angular instantánea en
un punto específico del recorrido y
podemos encontrar la aceleración angular
también usando esta fórmula el cambio en
la velocidad angular o mega entre el
cambio en el tiempo esto nos da la
aceleración angular es igual a omega
final menos omega inicial entre el
cambio en el tiempo que nos queda 1.57
que es nuestra velocidad angular final
menos cero que fue nuestra velocidad
angular inicial y a esto le llevo cuatro
segundos realizarse por lo que nuestra
aceleración angular resulta ser de punto
3 93 radiales por segundo por segundo o
radiales por segundo al cuadrado y esto
técnicamente es la aceleración angular
promedio pero si la aceleración angular
es constante en todo este recorrido la
cual será así en la mayoría de los
problemas que veamos aquí la aceleración
angular va a ser constante
es el caso esta será la aceleración
angular promedio y la aceleración
angular instantánea en cualquier punto
de este recorrido ya que la aceleración
angular se va a mantener constante en
este ejemplo podemos decir que el
desplazamiento angular fue de pi radian
es que la velocidad angular promedio fue
de punto 7 85 radiales por segundo y que
la velocidad angular inicial fue de 0 y
la velocidad angular final fue de 1.57
radiales por segundo y que la
aceleración angular es de 0.3 93
radiales por segundo al cuadrado en
resumen el desplazamiento angular
representa el ángulo que fue recorrido
al rotar el objeto y típicamente se mide
en radiales y se representa con delta
theta la velocidad angular representa la
tasa a la cual está rotando un objeto se
mide en radiales por segundo y se
representa con la letra griega o mega y
la aceleración angular representa la
tasa a la cual un objeto está cambiando
su velocidad
por lo que si un objeto rota a una tasa
constante tendrá una aceleración angular
igual a cero pero si al contrario un
objeto aumenta su velocidad o la
disminuye tendrá aceleración angular sus
unidades son radiales por segundo por
segundo o radiales por segundo al
cuadrado y se representa con la letra
griega alfa